انا كنت محتاج ان انا
اعمل نجاح
ينسب
الى المجموعه طبعا بس ينسب اليها كمام
بوضوح يعني مش بس دائما ابقى انا خالد
واخرين لكن لما انا خالد وصابرين
وطارق عبد العزيز مثلا
وبعض الزملاء وبعدين الولاد الصغيرين
وبعدين بس الانتظار انت شايف انه في راس
حربه همم مش لازم تقول اول اسم مش كل
الاعمال باحبها بس
يعني يعني بقى لي كذا سنه
همم في سليم بتجيء وسريعه جدا
وكفاءتك ما تفهمش اختياراتك بتبقى غلط همم
انا عصبي والعصبيه بتاعتي حاجه بتضرني
بتضرني بالصدام عنيد وده برده ساعات في
مشاكل همم
يعني لو انا عايز اعمل حاجه وهتكلفني جامد
جدا واخش الخناقه
وصدامي يعني انا صغير كنت باحث الارض
فكل الحاجات دي همم بتخليني احيانا محتاج
كنت همم الحكمه في سنين اصغر من كده فما
حصلش ههه
اعمل لها ايه هي دي شخصيتي راجل كبير في
حته عيله ايه برنامج همم همم كنت محتاج في
الوقت ده اني اتفادى الاخطاء اللي فاتت دي
واعمل عمل ينسى من المجموعه بس انثى بالله
يا بوضوحه